the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC I'm going to tell you today how the
rich and Powerful really control
American politics and it's so funny
because it sounds like a conspiracy
headline the truth about the elites
controlling our political system but
that's the joke that's what's funny
about it for all of the people looking
for the conspiracies for how American
politics is controlled oh it's a cabal
of pedophiles who trade kids and drink
the blood of children in exchange for
favors maybe outside a pizza shop I
don't know or it's an elite of Jewish
men maybe with space lasers or the
voting machine people
it's out in the open it's a conspiracy
out in the open the real way that the
rich and Powerful control American
politics is publicly known and we're
going to go over it here you don't need
to look for
the hidden conspiracy let's start with
campaign financing the cost of running
for office national office in the U.S is
huge and it continues going up which
means candidates rely on donations from
corporations and wealthy people in order
to fund their campaigns on average the
candidate that raises more money wins
and the donors expect something in
return for their investment it's out in
the open it's legalized bribery when a
candidate takes money from a donor the
donor on average has influence over the
candidate doesn't mean they're meeting
in person and saying here's what I need
you to do but it exerts some influence
for sure and they can expect at least
for the candidate to listen to them to
take their concerns into account when
making policy decisions and we find it
in the facts we find there's that famous
Princeton study from a few years ago
which found the legislative desires of
the wealthy and of course operations are
much more likely to be pursued as
legislation and made into law by our
elected officials then the concerns of
just the average person so it works it's
out in the open you don't need to search
for the secret way in which influence is
being wielded it's not just politicians
influenced by money the policy making
process itself is heavily influenced by
special interests and lobbyists which
then can come in and say focus on this
rather than that these are people who
are paid it's all legal to advocate for
certain policies on behalf of their
clients they often have access to
lawmakers that you and I don't they can
make their voices heard in ways that
average people can't and so it's another
part of the feedback loop that leads to
policies that may not be in the public
interest but they benefit the select few
that are using their money to get that
influence but that's money there's more
than just money that gives the rich and
Powerful control over American politics
they also have access to the best
strategists who can help them shape
public opinion focus group polling
market research and they can use those
strategists to influence the outcome of
Elections you and I don't have that we
can phone bank we can donate paltry sums
but we don't have access to that the
political strategists are experts at
crafting messages framing issues in ways
that are favorable to their clients and
to their their desires they've got the
data the market research to understand
what will work on voters and that's
another reason they are more likely to
succeed and then the third prong of this
is media and access to the media media
can be used in and of itself to shape
public opinion and to influence the
political discourse to include certain
topics and exclude others and of course
the money is used in order to influence
media and media plays a major role in
American politics we shouldn't we should
accurately assess what the media is and
isn't but we have no choice if we're
connected to reality to acknowledge that
media generates or wields the power to
decide what stories get covered and
which stories don't how are they
presented what's the framing can
something be inserted or excluded from
the public discourse which has a
dramatic impact on both elections and
also on legislation passing or not when
it comes to the wealthy and the powerful
they often get favorable coverage either
through their use of strategy gists and
PR people through their use of
advertising dollars and this can make it
really a a difficult thing an uphill
battle
for just the average person to have
their voice heard in the same way so
it's all in the open whenever you hear a
conspiracy theory about the secret
campaign to wield influence and the
elites control you could say we the why
it's it's all happening in the open
there's no need to find the secret way
in which it's being done now to counter
that influence what can be done
everybody has to be voting as a starting
point don't throw away the one vote you
have we should be educated and aware of
the ways in which this is taking place
place if you don't even know the
mechanisms it's going to be hard to to
fight against them and then support
candidates and policies that are number
one in the public interest but number
two would work to maybe diffuse or
reduce this disproportionate power that
the rich wealthy and corporations have
that's the way it is you don't need to
find some Secret conspiracy because it's
all happening out in the open
Barack Obama
accurately called out the toxic left at
a very interesting event called the
Obama Foundation Summit yesterday Obama
you remember that guy I have to tell you
I think what Barack Obama says here is
pretty damn accurate I have made clear
the toxic left is a small part of the
left but it exists and it's really
destructive and counterproductive Barack
Obama in this clip we're going to look
at hard to imagine a more accurate
assessment of this sliver of the left
let's take a listen you know this this
idea of Purity and you're never
compromised and you're always
politically woke and all that stuff you
should get over that quickly the world
the world is messy
their ambiguities
people who
do really good stuff
have flaws
people who you are fighting
may love their kids
and
you know
share certain things with you and and I
think that one danger I see among young
people particularly on College camps is
Malia and I talk about this Yara goes to
school with my daughter
um
but I do get a sense sometimes now among
certain young people and this is
accelerated by social media there is
this sense sometimes of the way of me
making change is to be as judgmental as
possible about other people
folks this is verbatim the stuff I've
been saying for four years on the show
these are genuinely wise words I've been
careful to say there is a small but very
loud part of the left
the right is almost completely Bonkers
nuts okay that's clear that's a clear
part of the show
but there is this slice of the left
that's very loud
and they will allow the perfect to
become the enemy of the good
they will use Purity tests they will
dismiss entire groups of people over uh
the narcissism of what we sometimes call
small differences and in my universe in
the left media platform they often try
to ruin what people like me and others
are doing because we're not perfect by
their standard
and this is part of why the left loses
slash doesn't win as much as we could
let's continue and that's enough like if
I tweet or hashtag about how you didn't
do something right or use the word wrong
verb or
then I can sit back and feel pretty good
about myself because man you see how
awoke I was I called you out
I'm gonna get on TV
watch my show
watch grown-ish
um
you know that's not
that's not activism
that's not bringing about change you
know
if if all you're doing is casting stones
uh you know you're probably not going to
get that far
that's easy to do
there are lots of people who I know
don't like this and these are the same
people that get mad at me sometimes when
I say hey you know it might be better to
get this win a tangible step forward but
we we might benefit from that even if
it's not perfect or even if some of the
people helping us get this win don't
agree with us about this other area here
particularly on some of these cultural
issues and the way I understand what the
former president is saying is that there
are shared values and desires that are
much broader than our exact political
orientation you might ask me about my
position on 50 different issues and you
and I might only agree on 30 but there
are some overriding values that we share
particularly that the right doesn't and
there's going to be ambiguity there are
contradictions we all you know as as
much as we all like to be consistent you
know when I say to you Hey listen
um
if I don't praise or blame a republican
for gas prices then I have to try to be
consistent and apply the same standard
to a Democratic president we're all
trying to be consistent but there are
contradictions and there are ambiguities
and some of them come from all sorts of
different things in our background or
our upbringing our education or whatever
the case may be the Nuance is great but
we can't allow those differences to get
in the way of the progress that is
available for all of us to take and this
includes things like to be perfectly
Frank
the idea of if it's not Bernie then I
don't care if it's Hillary or Trump it's
sort of all the same wow were those
people proven wrong and again it's a
small slice of the left but I love this
I think Barack Obama is absolutely spot
on here
reactionary populism that's the name we
should be using for this sort of newish
right wing that some call trumpism our
friend Aaron rupar
uh I believe with a guest writer named
Noah berlotsky has a nice piece on his
sub stack called Elon musk's reactionary
populism I want to zoom out from Elon
Musk a little bit and just kind of give
you a foundation to think about this
movement because we it's very easy and
popular now to say Maga isn't
conservative jire bolsonaro is not a
conservative uh the these are we're not
recognizing traditional conservatism in
this new movement what is it reactionary
populist I believe is something that
encapsulates it reactionary populism is
a political ideology
characterized by
populist rhetoric and using populist
rhetoric for the people right that's
what we're talking about when we say
population
populist rhetoric to oppose Progressive
social and Progressive political change
so it often will involve rejecting
established political institutions a
defense of Traditional Values and ways
of life but under the rhetoric because
remember populism is a rhetoric rather
than a set of policy ideas using the
rhetoric of populism for your opposition
we're against this trans stuff
because of what's best for the average
person and the people the average girl
playing sports the trans stuff is bad
for the so they use populist rhetoric to
oppose
relatively standard at this point quite
frankly Progressive political and social
change they focus on Nostalgia for a
past that may not even have existed
that's an important thing to understand
they refuse to acknowledge and address
the challenges that we have today
through this nostalgic focus on a past
past that may or may not have been real
they will resist the progressive social
and political change which can actually
hinder progress and hinder social
mobility in many cases they reject
established political institutions which
will often lead them to ignore the rule
of law that's sounding pretty familiar
when we think about Donald Trump and
mega trumpism they will defend
Traditional Values and ways of life but
not with the traditional conservative
rhetoric they will defend it with
populist sounding rhetoric which can
trick people
and this is how some left Wingers fall
prey and victim to right-wing populist
rhetoric they will often promote
nativist and protectionist policies like
around immigration uh justifying it by
saying this is what's good for the
people and of course in so doing they'll
harm global trade they'll destroy
alliances with other countries as we saw
under Trump they will resist
globalization generally they will resist
immigration they will resist social
diversity all using the pseudo populist
rhetoric of what's best for the people
and as we saw during the covid pandemic
the reactionary populists will often
reject evidence and expertise and that
can undermine public policy it can
undermine decision making it can
undermine the country coming together to
actually deal with issues perfectly
describes what happened thanks to the
Maga right under during the covet
pandemic under Donald Trump the reality
of course is that while the reactionary
populists will use rhetoric that sounds
like maybe it's sort of left-wing it's
not in the sense that this reactionary
populist movement is associated with the
far right far right political movements
extremists
Etc and it will all be under the guise
of we are under threat they will use
fear we are under threat it's a
political ideology rooted in reactionary
right-wing conservatism in a nationalist
worldview but it has been sort of passed
through a populist rhetoric filter so
examples include Trump of course the
Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
um French politician Marine Le Pen
Brazilian president former president Jr
bolsonaro these are leaders whose
supporters will often espouse populist
sounding rhetoric but they oppose
Progressive political change they oppose
Progressive social change they appeal to
a Nostalgia that may not exist and they
at the end of the day when you get to
policy which you don't always get to
with the reactionary populists they
promote nativist policy protectionist
policy and reactionary policy I think
that's as good a name as any reactionary
populism let me know your thoughts check
out Aaron and Noah's piece and we'll
follow up about this again
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at a fair price
guys know how tough it can be to find
good boxers and t-shirts the Search is
Over All boxer briefs by Leisure of NYC
are made with amazingly soft moisture
wicking viscose from bamboo it feels
super lightweight like air it doesn't
Bunch up it's also great for the planet
Leisure of NYC also makes these
incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's the best out there it
feels like Silk quite frankly you can
walk around in a scratchy t-shirt all
day or you can enjoy the cloud soft feel
of supima cotton and actually love the
shirt you're in these are my go-to
shirts and boxers nobody else even comes
close to the Comfort they provide all
products are fair trade with
sustainability in mind pick some up for
yourself or someone on your holiday
shopping list go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
in a truly shocking and disturbing move
the Texas Attorney General is demanding
that the state's Health Department
release a list of all transgender people
in the state by asking for a list of
those who have requested changing their
sex on documents this has sparked
outrage among not only the LGBT
community but also their allies people
like me who see it as a blatant attack
on the rights and the privacy of trans
individuals The Washington Post has a
report Texas AG's office sought State
data on trans Texans employees at the
Texas Department of Public Public Safety
in June received a sweeping request from
Republican attorney general Ken Paxton's
office compile a list of individuals who
changed their gender on their Texas
driver's license and other Department
Records during the past two years now
why does the AG claim they need this
they say we need this list
to defend a state law that requires
people to use bathrooms that correspond
with the gender on their birth
certificate but it's very obvious what
this is this is a thinly veiled attempt
to start generating a list which could
be used to Target it could be used to
harass trans people the Attorney General
is using this pretext of we've got to
defend Law and Order In order to gather
information personal information about
trans people in the state now I
I don't want to be hyperbolic or or a
dystopian here but we should understand
history
and the right loves to talk about camps
they say Obama is going to put you in a
FEMA camp Obama or you know they they
talk about camps they're obsessed with
camps and rounding people up and all of
that
we should understand and I'm not saying
that's the direction this is going in
Texas but we should just understand
historically what have been the steps
that are taken before actually putting
people in camps or overtly starting
violent actions against groups of people
like if that's what you were planning to
do what would be on the list of things
that we would we would want to watch out
for and this is where history is
actually very important to understand
historically
what you see in the lead up to an
attempt to go after a population whether
it's for discrimination or enslavement
or genocide or whatever right it's a big
spectrum of what one might plan to do
here are some of the steps and you don't
always see all of these incitement of
hatred and violence against a group so
this can include using propaganda to
make people angry at that group look
look at what the right has been doing
when it comes to trans people and
transports and bathrooms and so-called
predators and pedophiles for years now
okay so use propaganda and other tactics
to demonize dehumanize and direct anger
so that hostility goes up and
willingness to do violence goes up
against a particular group of people
that's happening with trans people no
doubt about it economic and social
discrimination so the targeted group
might be denied access to something
could be education could be employment
could be some other resource this leads
to being economically marginalized and
socially marginalized another aspect to
watch out for you sometimes will see
political and uh legal discrimination
the targeted group might be denied some
right could be the right to vote that's
not happening with trans people could be
to hold public office could be just
basic rights that would typically be
protected under the law You could argue
that in some ways the right is not
arguing for that by saying well sexual
orientation or gender identity should
not be a protected class
they don't want it to be uh that's
another aspect and then as things
escalate you might see systematic
violence against a group The targeted
group could be subjected to physical
violence and verbal abuse uh that that
is considered acceptable in society and
of course in crazy you know when things
in instances in history that really get
bad you're talking about rape torture
and other forms of brutality there could
be forced displacement where the
targeted group is removed from their
homes or communities either through
direct violence or through policies and
practices that make it impossible for
them to remain so the big examples of
course you've got the Holocaust you had
Force displacement you had legal
discrimination systematic violence
The Armenian Genocide another example
incitement of hatred and violence
through propaganda economic and social
discrimination political and legal
discrimination systematic violence Force
displacement
um and I think another example that
would be at the top of the list is the
Rwandan Genocide incitement of hatred
and violence through propaganda
absolutely economic and social
discrimination political and legal
discrimination systematic violence Force
displacement so
we're not saying that's the plan of
these right Wingers with trans people if
they got their way but when you start
asking for lists any sensible person is
going to say that's a red flag and the
reason they're citing they need that
list is simply not believable really
scary stuff happening in Texas
uh Donald Trump being dishonest and
scamming his followers
say it ain't so
Donald Trump kept for himself most of
the 147 million dollars that he raised
supposedly for the 2022 midterms now you
might ask why do the same people keep
falling for this stuff over and over
again we will get to that Huffington
Post reports Trump hoarded most of the
147 million in small donor money he
raised for himself just weeks after
touting a new Super PAC writes SV de te
for HuffPost in the November supposedly
to help Republican candidates in the
November midterms Trump wound up
spending just a fraction of the hundred
million he had available
and he hoarded the rest for his own 2024
presidential run the coup attempting
former president in October transferred
60 million dollars from his save America
leadership pack to his make America
great again Inc Super PAC which was
ostensibly to boost candidates in tight
races Republican candidates it collected
another 9 million from an existing
pro-trump Super Pac and then 4 million
in new contributions of that 73 million
dollar total though
only 15 million dollars went to electing
Republicans in just five Senate races
according to a HuffPost analysis of FEC
filings with not a dime spent helping
Herschel Walker in Georgia
a full 54 million dollars remains
available for the super pac's new stated
goal helping Trump win back the White
House remember in late September uh
Taylor budowich who is now the head of
Maga Inc and was a spokesperson for
Trump's pack told Politico quote
president Trump is committed to saving
America and make America great again Inc
will ensure that is achieved at The
Ballot Box in November and Beyond
uh he's keeping the money he's keeping
the money so let's get back to that
interesting question
why do the same people keep falling for
the same stuff over and over again
it's important to understand cult
membership
and it's important to understand sort of
victimization it's crazy that these are
the terms we have to think about one
reason
cult members remain part of the cult
is they have a strong belief in the
group's ideology that makes them
vulnerable to being manipulated or
controlled by the cult leader in this
case it's Trump I scammed you once and
again and again and again after the 2020
election saying we were going to
overturn it and now I'm scamming you
again it's the same scam because they're
loyal to the ideology they are
predisposed to be manipulated oftentimes
cult members have a strong emotional
attachment to the group and to its
leaders and that is absolutely the case
with Donald Trump that makes it
difficult for them to break away and to
stop being scammed by the cult leader
the cult followers also are sometimes
isolated from the outside world in this
case we might call it isolated from
everything other than Maga trumpism that
makes it tough for them to even get
other inputs about hey he might be
scamming you again friends and family
try to tell them you're getting scammed
stop donating doesn't happen they've
remain vulnerable so you've got cult
membership you then also need to look at
scam victims scam victims are often
victimized by scammers multiple times
it's really common and it fits here as
well some people seem to just be more
susceptible to scams either because of
their emotional vulnerability
psychological vulnerability lack of
Education lack of knowledge about scams
sometimes it's they're lonely
and donating to Trump is a way to be
part of a group or they have low
self-esteem or they want to be validated
Trump's emails are quite literally
exactly those we want to put you on a
list of Trump's best and biggest
supporters oh that sounds validating
that's interesting and then there are
some people who are just a little too
trusting or naive and they are more
vulnerable to be scammed so repeat
victims of scams really common cult
followers who just never realize it's a
cult really common and trumpists many of
them are that perfect combination of
people predisposed to be scammed
and predisposed to falling for a cult
leader I would say a charismatic cult
leader to some degree Trump is
charismatic in in ways that I think
would appeal to Maga and next thing you
know Trump's raising tens of millions
again saying I'm going to help 2022
candidates and he's keeping the money
what will he use it for probably to try
to help himself win in 2024 whether or
not that happens is increasingly in
question make sure that you were
subscribed to the David Pacman show on
YouTube at youtube.com
the David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
it's great to Welcome to the program
today Allison Butler who's a contributor
to the media and me a guide to critical
media literacy for young people and also
the director of the media literacy
certificate program at my undergraduate
alma mater the University of
Massachusetts in Amherst Allison it's
really great having you on I appreciate
it thanks so much I'm really excited to
be here so I mean I guess let's just
start with something it's a simple
question the answer may not be so simple
but it's something I I talk about a lot
media literacy I think should start
being taught at the latest in seventh
grade to everybody probably fifth grade
is even better it's pretty rare
particularly that public schools have
media literacy programs is it as simple
as it's just not a priority to those
creating the curricula or is there more
to why it's not commonly taught
I think there's more commonly taught and
I would you know raise your fifth to
seventh grade to say we need to start an
early childhood education our children
are exposed to the media within you know
immediately
um and certainly with social media we
can learn a lot about them before
they're born uh their identities are out
there really early on uh I think yes it
is something that is really can be
understood to be difficult to add to the
curriculum and part of the reason why
it's difficult is we don't have formal
training formal education for people who
want to teach media literacy so
oftentimes teachers have to kind of
figure it out on their own and goodness
knows they have enough to do so to ask
them to add more is arduous part of our
work part of my work is to say we need
teacher education and media literacy
yeah that's interesting because the I
remember that there were these kind of
one-off classes in middle and high
school that were interesting I remember
one called like Transportation power and
energy which was really interesting it
didn't really fit anywhere and the
teacher who taught it was not certainly
an expert in that field and sort of had
to figure it out as as he went and so it
does seem that part of the problem as
you're pointing out is it's not common
that the teacher base is necessarily
equipped to teach media literacy
correct I talk with teachers all the
time who say that they're really
interested in bringing in the study of
the media to their classrooms
particularly because they see how glued
to their devices their students are but
then they're at a loss for how to teach
it formally I think also sometimes like
you mentioned these kind of one-off
classes they can often be seen as like
what you get to do when you're done with
what you're supposed to be studying yes
yes absolutely which is sure that's
that's I mean there's value in that
right there's absolute value in that I
wouldn't say that that was prob that was
that that's a bad idea but I do think
it's bad if it's the only way that we're
teaching it because our media are so
infused in our lives why would we then
think about educating them as like an
add-on or
um as something to do when you're done
the important stuff
by the time people get to you so at the
college level what do you find are the
most common blind spots in being able to
look at media and think about it
critically in terms of you know we we
often hear really young kids can't tell
the difference between advertising and
content for example or
um people can't necessarily distinguish
between whether they're watching news or
opinion programming is a more common one
for older people what are the most
common blind spots by the time people
are college age and get to you
I I mean I'd say there's probably two
really big ones that can then Branch out
into so many more one for the most part
by the time they get to me they're
pretty good at understanding the content
but they don't know where that content
comes from they don't know the power
behind the content and that's part of a
lot of the work that I do and that my
colleagues and I do in um in the media
and me is say it's not just about what's
on the screen or just what we're hearing
the actual Powers behind the scenes we
have to talk about ownership production
and distribution and I'd say connected
to that but the other big area is Again
by the time students come to my
classroom as college students freshmen
through seniors they're really invested
in media they're involved in a lot of
media they have multiple social media
accounts but have no clue where their
information is going uh social media is
a huge tool of surveillance massive
amounts of data Gathering probably safe
to say that most if not all of us zip
through those terms of service zip
through those privacy documents don't
read the truly truly fine fine print and
all the paragraphs of legalese we sign
off on them it's the only way that we
have access to these platforms and yet
we have no idea where our information is
going what's happening to it the one
clue that we get is often as soon as we
search for something
quite quickly after that an
advertisement for that very thing will
pop up we gave away the data that let
that happen
that's pretty dangerous do you find that
over the last 10 years the usage of
social media among 18 to 22 year olds
has changed in any appreciable way I
mean one of the things I've read is that
on average people's use of Facebook is
going in the direction of fewer friends
and tending towards people you really
know rather than a larger circle of
friends like that's a change in terms of
average Facebook use but do you see that
the 18 to 22 year olds are thinking of
their social media presences differently
than maybe a decade ago oh absolutely I
mean I think maybe some of what's going
on with young people in Facebook is that
they I mean you know once people my age
got onto Facebook it became a lot less
interesting for young people and you
know now that Grandma's there right kind
of like makes it less fun I guess
um so I understand from my students that
they use something like Facebook almost
more for like School connections or
school projects as a way of connecting
with people
um but I think that in terms of their
own personal use of social media it's a
source of anxiety uh that it's meant at
least at some points for them to be fun
and as its name for it to be social but
it can be remarkably anti-social you're
often pretty isolated with it and
certainly some of those comparisons
against the beautiful airbrushed images
are incredibly difficult uh but they're
also entering a world where they're
expected to know how to use this
professionally and so that anxiety is
not just about self but it's also about
their preparation for their future and
what's like sort of what's to come next
and I think in some ways met like like
all of us do with certain areas of our
life is that young people can kind of
become their own worst enemies they will
be upset or concerned about once it's
introduced to them about some of these
surveillance Technologies but one of the
biggest things that's happening these
days is that young people use the find
my app where they are constantly
tracking where their friends are and
what I hear from my students is they use
it so that when they don't text a friend
back their friend knows it's because
they're in a class where they're not
supposed to have their phones on so as
much as they might get frustrated by
being surveilled they also are
participating in that speaking of phones
in class
um I last taught as an adjunct at Boston
College in 2017 and it was a once a week
class so it was just like listen we're
here once a week week I don't want to
see any phones period just absolutely no
phones they're on laptops I don't know
what they're doing on the laptops I
don't really want to get involved in
that but it was just like there should
never be a phone that's out how much of
an active distraction is whether they're
on social media or not the phones in the
classroom right now what's your sense of
that
oh I think they're a huge distraction
it's so hard for us not to look at our
phones I actually have a policy in my
class that unless there is a documented
accommodation need no cell phones no
computers and stop looking at your smart
watches that were here to discuss ideas
there's no tests in my class there's no
final exam this is about engaging with
each other and engaging with with our
discussions uh and most of them can't
really put their phones away they sort
of turn them over on their desks I will
watch them get up and leave the room for
a few moments and I'm assuming they're
checking their phones but they don't
want to get like caught checking it in
class and at the end it there's there's
stress about that and some of them do
get frustrated with me but at the end of
the semester the consistent commentary I
get is this is the one class I actually
paid attention to
um because I couldn't be distracted
that's interesting that's interesting to
to get kind of back to the media
literacy part a couple other things to
talk about
when it comes to how do I identify a
trustworthy source
anybody who's been in this field any
length of time we we know about all of
the things that are often said and it
they tend to involve research they tend
to evolve you know it's not oh hey
here's an article I just found I'm very
in 30 seconds going to be able to do all
of the things that on paper we often say
here's how you identify whether a source
is trustworthy what's the lowest hanging
fruit that any news consumer can employ
to try to suss out whether an article or
a video clip or whatever the case may be
is coming from a source that can be
trusted
I think the first thing to do is is an
author mentioned because if an author
isn't mentioned who knows how that got
put together it could be PR
um do you know the website right does it
and look closely at the website because
websites are easily manipulated so you
could have like you know New York Times
Dash com dot Gmail or you know right and
then you're like wait I saw the New York
Times but then it's something totally
different right um so truly look at the
ending of the website almost of the URL
almost before looking at the beginning
does it look like a real website
can you get back to that article without
you I mean look at everything is going
to have pop-up ads but if it's the ones
that are just like overtaking your
screen can you learn more about the
author you don't have to like what they
say but can you actually learn more
about this person and if not I would be
suspicious about whether or not that
person is either actually a person
um or you know potentially a bot or so
on and so forth or if it's somebody
who's kind of hiding behind some other
sort of idea or some other sort of
message so those would be the absolute
first things I would also say be really
cautious about maybe the next level
would be really cautious about what you
click on on social media social media
platforms are not news platforms we can
share news on them
but they are not news platforms so if we
you know like if we talk to young people
who say like oh I get most of my news
from Twitter well no you don't you get
information on Twitter that somebody
might have shared right that might be
news you're finding links on Twitter
exactly yeah you're finding links on
Twitter another thing that seems
critical that I tell people is TR make
an attempt to get to the primary source
if there actually is one because there's
so you know there will be situations
where not to pick on any of these
particular news outlets but you'll see a
raw story article with a headline and it
will quote Newsweek it's actually a
Newsweek article that they are
summarizing and editorializing you go to
the Newsweek article and Newsweek
actually says as reported by The
Washington Post and so you drilling down
to where did this actually come from
seems like a fundamental first step in
evaluating it because really all Raw
Story might be doing is rewriting an
article you can't really ascertain the
truth of the matter you can ascertain
whether it's honestly Rewritten but not
the the underlying reporting and so
finding the primary source seems really
important a lot of people may not
realize the difference between a
Rewritten blog style article and the
reporting
yep absolutely and that's true I mean I
think one thing to you're absolutely
right is who is being sourced and our
source is being named are those the
primary sources is you know if something
says something to the effect of like
research shows well where's that
research I should be able I might not be
able to distill the research myself that
quickly but I should be able to access
the research I also think that
especially in the previous uh
presidential Administration the idea of
unnamed sources right what does it mean
for a source to go a name for some for
some stories that is really legitimate
there are dangerous issues why
somebody's name out there could be a
problem but for others it's it's a it's
a kind of a circuitous Route Around
citing your sources so part of our work
in the media knee and part of our work
in critical media literacy is
evidence-based research we want to
provide evidence ourselves and we want
people to be looking for evidence
themselves there was a even confusion
during the Trump era of when we talk
about an anonymous source are they known
to the reporter and there were countless
instances where people misunderstood
that even the reporter didn't know who
the person was when the reporter did
it's just they weren't they weren't
naming them and that's a critical
difference
absolutely absolutely 100 we've been
speaking with Allison Butler contributor
to the media and me a guide to critical
media literacy for young people also
director of the media literacy
certificate program at UMass Allison
really great having you on I appreciate
your time
thanks so much David it was great
chatting with you
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show continuing
our conversation from earlier about
cults and scams we have to talk about
Carrie Lake Carrie Lake who lost her
attempt at becoming governor of Arizona
is still talking about suing to overturn
the election at this point I don't even
know if the people hosting her believe
this dribble here is Carrie Lake on with
Tucker Carlson last night and she is
still acting like there's actually
something going on here that might allow
her to become the governor of Arizona
she won't she won't listen to this we
vote for a full month in Arizona with
early ballots and on Election Day when
the Republicans showed up the election
day voting was sabotaged and that it was
not sabotaged a few tabulators briefly
didn't work they were fixed it's what
our case is going to prove it's a
70-page lawsuit that reads like a real
crime novel yeah it I mean it reads like
a crime novel in the sense that it's
fiction uh this was overall a bizarre
interview here's how Tucker Carlson
introduced Kerry Lake and this is he
devoted four and a half minutes to this
which on the one hand isn't a lot but
for a Fox News segment for something so
absurd they often will do two-minute
interviews and this is a four and a half
minute interview we won't watch all of
it don't worry I won't subject you to
that
according to official tallies Kerry Lake
lost her bid to become the next Arizona
governor by just over 17 000 votes
that's a tiny margin in a big state now
lake is suing the state's election
officials she says many ballots were not
properly counted she also says her
opponent then Secretary of State Katie
Hobbs worked illegally with big Tech to
sounds voters online and for the record
that appears to be true there is not
actually evidence of that lake is also
setting widespread printer failures in
Maricopa County also true she says they
prevented people from voting Maricopa
County claims they didn't stop anyone
from voting but has not responded
further we reached out to Kitty Hawk Now
understand the way they they manipulate
language Maricopa County has said they
did not prevent anyone from voting but
they have not responded further it is
not on them to respond further Kerry
lake has not actually presented evidence
of that these folks I want to say they
don't understand
they certainly pretend at least not to
understand burden of proof I was his
office and got no reply at all Carrie
Lake joins us tonight Kelly thanks so
much for coming on what an important
conversation we're going to have so
Maricopa County is as far as I
understand it does not deny that a huge
number of printers didn't work on
Election Day but they're saying it had
no effect
I don't know what Kerry Lake's going to
say here we're going to check it out in
a moment
um remember
they don't deny it the Republican Party
filed a lawsuit initially over the
broken tabulators once they were
satisfied a few tabulators briefly
didn't work everyone who wanted to vote
voted everything was okay the Republican
Party retracted that lawsuit
people are satisfied other than Kerry
Lake
well and it had a huge effect obviously
Tucker our our voters were showing up on
Election Day that was no secret and the
minute the polls opened the wheels fell
off the ballot printers weren't working
there wasn't enough toner in the
printers the tabulators weren't working
it became a debacle and the line started
forming right away some of the lines
three hours four hours five hours and
there's video of people walking out of
line people told us and this is in our
lawsuit that they showed up they
couldn't even find parking because the
parking lots were full and the lines
were long and many people didn't even
get to vote and those who did vote when
they went up to uh you know get the
printer out the printer didn't have
toner in it so the the ballots weren't
dark enough and our voters were showing
up and voting three to one to uh on for
me on Election Day think of that that
none of that is even remotely believable
and there's no evidence for any of it
but listen she's filed a lawsuit so I
guess I guess yes at some point it'll
all come out right like Mike pillow used
to always say remember pillow we're
doing a
drink and yet the information never
seems to make its way out vote for a
full month in Arizona with early battle
all right and this is the segment that
you already heard Carrie Lake then
appearing on real America's voice again
to give an update on this lawsuit now
again I just don't know does Carrie Lake
really believe this is going to go
anywhere or is it just a way to raise
money because if you actually look below
uh in these tweets she responds donate
to my legal fund save Arizona fund is
this just another grift to try to make
money or does she genuinely believe this
might go anywhere listen to this update
from her we had three whistleblowers
from Maricopa County reach out and say
the system is flawed seriously flawed
the three levels they have to determine
if a signature is valid or not they were
throwing out tens of thousands of
signatures saying they were scribbles
they in no way matched but somewhere
between there and the ball is being
completely tossed out they got looped
back into the system encounted as if
they were fine this is crazy are you
even sometime between
the mismatch on the signature she claims
exists and the ballots being tossed they
were counted as if they were fine
so is the problem that ballots were
counted or weren't carry I guess it's
both and they had no flagging done and
they laid it out how that happened how
somewhere between being flagged as a bad
signature and going into the curing
process which would mean they were cured
sauteed and later cold smoked phone
calls or emails to the actual voter to
see if they wanted to come in and verify
their signature dear God it wasn't
happening there was a disconnect there
and there's a disconnect all right and
part of the disconnect is
first the problem was disenfranchisement
people didn't get to vote now the
problem is too many people voted whose
votes shouldn't actually count here's
the real position right
her supporters weren't allowed to vote
and people who didn't really mean to
vote for Katie Hobbs
had their votes counted for Katie Hobbs
but I guess those would be her
supporters right I mean it doesn't
really make any sense if her supporters
weren't allowed to vote and votes that
weren't really for Katie Hobbs were
accounted for Katie Hobbs those
wrongfully counted votes for Katie Hobbs
must have been her voters so they were
allowed to vote except part of the
argument is there wasn't if you don't
know what I'm talking about it's because
it doesn't make any sense three
whistleblowers said that they believed
that a second level manager was pushing
these through these rejected ballots
pushing them through as if they were
approved and we did some calculations
and we believe that up to a hundred and
thirty five thousand ballots were pushed
through that should not have been pushed
through we're asking a judge to let us
take a look at all of the yeah it's just
not going to happen and again I don't
know whether she believes this crap or
whether she just needs to get her
followers to believe it none of it makes
sense there's no evidence for all of it
it's 2020 all over again lawsuit lawsuit
lawsuit they're all thrown out out if
and when something is actually granted
they'll say no no no no but you're just
looking at those bogus ballots and just
counting them again we need to actually
throw them out it'll be the same thing
nothing will happen carry Lake loss
Katie Hobbs is going to be the governor
of Arizona that's the bottom line Sorry
to people holding out hope if there are
actually any that somehow Carrie Lake
will end up Governor it's as likely as
that Trump will end up reinstated from
2020 which I guess some people believe
will happen but it's not going to Donald
Trump has hit a humiliating seven year
low in polling as Joe Biden is seeing
his approval rating climb since the 2022
midterms there's really interesting
Dynamics developing in National politics
this is not about the 2024 election this
is about how it is interesting to think
historically of circumstances in which
current or out-of-office elected
officials see dramatic changes in
approval rating and to understand what
precipitates that so let's start with
the news CNBC reports Trump hits
seven-year low in the new National poll
as Biden approval climbs about a month
after launching his 24 campaign Trump's
standing with voters has hit its lowest
point in more than seven years this is
according to a Quinnipiac University
poll released yesterday only 31 percent
of registered voters surveyed hold a
favorable view of trump
verses 59 unfavorable that's the lowest
rating Trump has received since July
2015. shortly after we launched his
first presidential bid so two ways to
interpret that one historic low and
Trump is going down in flames
Counterpoint this is as bad as it was
for Trump when he started running in
2015 and he ended up being president of
the United States so maybe we shouldn't
write it off uh meanwhile what about uh
Joe Biden Joe Biden's approval rating
still underwater is at its highest
rating since September of 2021.
um just 43 of respondents say they
approve of Biden 49 disapprove but that
is a significant increase from last
month and Biden has not yet announced
that he's running in 2024 but it is
increasingly looking that way and so
Trump down Biden up so
check out this list of ideas about how
someone can raise their approval rating
and I think you'll very quickly see why
it may be a problem for Donald Trump
effective leadership people seeing you
as doing effective leadership Trump's
not in office so that's going to be
really difficult
handling important issues well Trump's
not in office so it's going to be hard
to do that these are ways that people in
power can raise approval rating good
communication skills well sure I mean I
guess if Trump somehow became good at
communicating that would be useful uh
being responsive to constituents Trump
doesn't care about constituents that's
hilarious
um economic performance Trump's not in
power so it would be hard to do that so
given that Trump is not an office what
can elected officials out of office do
to raise their approval rating okay stay
visible and engage with the public even
if you're not in public office you can
become visible and engaged by doing
public events media appearances speeches
rallies Etc well Fox News and many other
prominent media don't seem to want to
interview Donald Trump and it's not
totally clear how quickly he is going to
go back to rallies but I guess
potentially holding rallies might be
something Trump can do although having 4
000 people go to see speak I don't know
if that's really going to move the
needle nationally secondly Trump can be
vocal on important issues even if he's
not the one handling them he can speak
out about issues facing the country
Trump could do that except mostly when
he gets the opportunity to speak the
issues are the 2020 election was rigged
we have a problem with men in women's
sports as he likes to say it
and the country is now communist
not exactly the type of stuff that's
going to raise your approval rating and
then lastly Trump can build a strong
team that inspires confidence and there
are rumors Trump might soon announce who
would be his VP I don't know if he's
going to do that we'll see
but often it seems as though Trump's
team is getting worse and that right now
it's a very ragtag low end team even
compared to what he had in 2016 and
2020. the additional problem Trump has
right now
is that there's a significant faction of
the Republican party that's preemptively
breaking away for Ron DeSantis even
though Ron DeSantis hasn't announced
that he's running for anything yet so
it's gonna be tough
it's not looking great for Donald Trump
but I think the important thing is if
Trump does get the nomination the people
that break away for DeSantis mostly will
fall in line and vote for Trump because
they hate Democrats way more than they
dislike Trump
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P here is a caller who's
upset
that I didn't end up reviewing the my
pillow pillows and that it was Pat who
did
Alan from Jersey I'm watching the bonus
show yeah you know the bonus show where
all you want to do is make money but
everybody else that makes money is bad
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad exactly
and you promised us that you would
review the pillows yes now Mike pillow
broke his promise because he never sent
you the pillows until you finally shamed
him into sending you the pillows okay
fine he broke his promise but eventually
he did send you the pillows but you
broke your promise or you promised to
review the pillows not not send your soy
boy Packer review the pillows right no
you promised to review the pillows and
fine okay Pat you know you're too busy
you know Mr big shot David pack like too
busy to review pillows so you sent your
story voice had to refuse them but Pat
didn't even review them Pat said he
tried the pills for 20 minutes in debug
no that's not a review okay listen guys
this isn't a pillow show so they didn't
send me the pillows then they offered to
because they heard I was telling people
pillow didn't send me the pillows I told
Pat quite frankly I've got enough
pillows and I've got a lot on my plate
Pat tried the pillows he couldn't even
fall asleep so yes after 20 minutes he
bailed and switched back to his normal
pillows that's the review we were able
to do sir I apologize with tears in my
eyes if you want to see Pat's review of
my pillow pillows
um it's on the bonus show earlier this
week we've got a great bonus show for
you today we'll talk about the border
wall we'll talk about Elon musk's
censoring speech on Twitter could it be
we will talk about a call to end Georgia
runoff elections and so much more sign
up at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
they're Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC